[Music]
thomas you seem triggered can you tell
me what happened
i've had dreams that weren't just dreams
[Music]
after all these years
to be going back to where it all started
back to the matrix
am i crazy we don't use that word in
here
are you
[Music]
no one can be told what the matrix is
but if you want it you gotta fight for
it i'm done fighting
no one can be told what the matrix is
you got to see it
to believe it
i know it's why you're still fighting
and why you will never give up
come on
thomas
[Music]
you seem particularly triggered right
now can you tell me what happened
i've had dreams that weren't just dreams
am i crazy
we don't use that word in here
[Music]
hi
have we met
one pill makes you larger and
one pill makes you small
and the ones that mother gives you
[Music]
time to fly
[Music]
[Music]
the only thing that matters to you is
still here i know it's why you're still
fighting
and why you will never give up
you don't know me
no
logics
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
see
after all these years to be going back
to where it all started
back to the matrix
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you